[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui si vous
Christian Gravel bonjour bienvenue sur
ce plateau merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes préfet président de
la mi-vilue de la Mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires un
organisme public qui fête ses 20 ans ces
jours-ci et dont le dernier rapport
Cristian Gravel fait un constat
alarmante le phénomène sectaire n'a
jamais été aussi important ici en France
je confirme contrairement à ce que
certains pouvaient penser ce phénomène
est prégnant depuis des décennies même
sur notre territoire et à l'échelle
internationale mais on a constaté
notamment l'occasion notre dernier
rapport d'activité que le nombre de
saisines dont nous faisions l'objet à
une croissance exponentielle en quelques
années on a eu 86% d'augmentation en 6
ans on est passé à plus de 4000 saisines
par an sachant que il faut avoir en tête
que c'est saisine ne sont que le reflet
de tendance lourde permettant de
témoigner de la vivacité dynamisme de
ces phénomènes sectaires dans notre dans
notre territoire national votre rapport
dit plusieurs choses on va aller
détailler ensemble d'une part notamment
que donc l'offre sectaire n'a jamais été
aussi vaste et qu'elle n'a jamais été
aussi diffusée elle est extrêmement
diffuse puisque au-delà des grandes
institutions sectaires que l'on connaît
depuis des années nationales de la
science
évidemment
nous avons constaté l'émergence d'une
multitude d'acteurs beaucoup plus
discret touchant des groupes plus diffus
plus discrètement puisque ils usent des
réseaux sociaux de la capacité du web à
pouvoir constituer des communautés
beaucoup plus discrètes permettant
évidemment de transcender les frontières
et de pouvoir diffuser leurs messages
pour pouvoir derrière tâcher dans
doctriner un certain nombre d'adeptes et
de faire en sorte que ils puissent
passer sous l'emprise de ces
entrepreneurs sectaires donc on voit
bien qu'on est conf à l'émergence de ces
gourous 2.0 qui profitent précisément
des capacités offertes par la révolution
numérique par le web pour pouvoir
élargir leurs bases et toucher un nombre
de publics un public de plus en plus
vaste un public de plus en plus vaste et
de plus en plus jeune
toutes les générations sont concernées
par les dérives sectaires comme tous les
territoires le sont comme toutes les
catégories sociales le sont il faut
sortir d'un préjugé ça n'a rien à voir
avec la bêtise ou la naïveté il n'y a
pas de prédisposition
il y a tout simplement des circonstances
qui peuvent toucher chacune et chacun
d'entre nous à savoir un moment dans
votre vie avec fragilité les
vulnérabilités qui sont exploitées dans
ces cas-là par ces entrepreneurs
sectaires qui savent comment prendre le
pouvoir sur votre esprit sur votre
cerveau
prendre le pouvoir sur votre libre
arbitre et faire en sorte de vous
manipuler et de s'inscrire dans une
démarche qui se traduit systématiquement
par des préjudices à caractère financier
physique avec beaucoup d'agressions
d'abus
à caractère psychologique par définition
ce que vous dites c'est que
sur des sujets
d'inquiétude et ils sont nombreux ces
dernières années vous l'avez évoqué la
crise sanitaire bien sûr mais aussi la
crise écologique et puis d'autres sujets
que dont on parle beaucoup notamment le
rapport à soi une grande partie des
saisines de la mivilud concerne des
questions de santé la santé est un sujet
prégnant dans le cadre des dérives
sectaires c'est normal par définition
une personne qui est confrontée à la
maladie et plus fragile s'interroge peut
être soumise à des traitements
douloureux étaient en quête par
définition bien souvent de méthodes
alternatives que des prédateurs
sectaires peuvent proposer cumulant
dérive thérapeutiques et dérive
sectaires avec ces phénomènes d'emprise
mentales on vous promettant des recettes
miracles en vous incitant à couper les
ponts avec tout ce qui relève de la
médecine conventionnelle tout ce qui
relève de la science mais en général et
par conséquent un isolement un repli sur
soi qui est exploité par ces par ses
prédateurs sectaires et je vous confirme
que la question de la santé est
évidemment une question qui est toujours
aussi importante dans le cadre des
statistiques que nous mettons en place
puisque par définition à l'occasion de
la crise sanitaire laquelle nous sommes
confrontés à laquelle nous avons été
confrontés un climat anxiogène à
favoriser ce cette recherche de méthode
alternative puisque la peur le stress
les inquiétudes extrêmement fortes ont
caractérisé un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens et donc sont allés chercher
parmi malheureusement un certain nombre
de charlatans qui sont potentiellement
dangereux un certain nombre de méthodes
de recettes pour pouvoir essayer de
trouver d'une part des réponses à leurs
questions à leur maladie mais plus
globalement essayez de trouver des
réponses à la quête de sens aux
questionnements que les uns et les
autres peuvent se poser étant donné les
bouleversements du monde auxquels nous
sommes confrontés
dans le rapport vous faites tout un vous
définissez tout le spectre de personnes
qu'on peut trouver donc on parle de
guérisseur de de chaman de ce genre ci
c'est ça toutes les toutes les formes
possibles de de pratique alternative
c'est-à-dire s'inscrivant d'une certaine
manière en opposition avec la médecine
conventionnelle s'inscrivant dans la
raison qui est au cœur de notre
tradition des Lumières
ont vu leur chiffre se déployaient et
donc leur capacité de capter l'attention
d'un public encore une fois de plus en
plus fragile l'enjeu étant de faire le
distinguo entre ce qui relève
effectivement de pratiques sectaires
avec une forme d'emprise vous l'avez dit
des conséquences financières ou
physiques sur les personnes qui en sont
victimes et puis des pratiques qui vont
peut-être à contre-courant mais qui l'a
relève plus d'une liberté de conscience
personnelle la politique liée aux
dérives sectaires date d'une quarantaine
d'années avec d'abord une prise de
position des parlementaires sur la
question des sectes et puis depuis 20
ans on a vécu une évolution juridique
extrêmement forte avec l'adoption de la
loi Abu Picard et depuis 20 ans donc qui
correspond également à la date
anniversaire de la mivilique comme vous
l'avez rappelé nous avons pris en
considération le fait que la liberté de
conscience de croyance d'opinions et par
définition une liberté fondamentale à
laquelle on n'a pas vocation à toucher
donc vous avez le droit de croire ce que
vous voulez en France quel que soit le
caractère parfois c'est
original
même fantasmatique qui peut être en face
de vous par contre ce qui relève de la
responsabilité de l'État c'est notre
devoir d'intervenir lorsque l'ordre
public ou lorsque des individus sont
clairement mis en danger lorsqu'il y a
une mise en danger la vie d'autrui et
c'est dans ce cadre-là que nous agissons
donc si nous intéresse ce ne sont pas
les structures et leur doctrines ce qui
nous intéresse ce sont les dérives
potentiels se traduisant par encore une
fois des préjudices divers et variés
mettant à mal la liberté de conscience
pour le coup et la santé de ces de ces
individus donc notre rôle est de veiller
à ce que on puisse intervenir lorsque
nous sommes alertés lorsque nous sommes
alertés la plupart du temps par des
proches de victimes à travers le site de
la mivil Lude mi-vilud point
intérieur.gouv.fr qui permet d'être en
contact avec des experts des conseillers
d'ami-vilud dont je salue
l'investissement et le professionnalisme
ce sont des experts qui connaissent
l'ensemble des sujets et qui sont en à
mesure de vous mettre en contact
également avec les bons services les
associations pour vous accompagner dans
le cadre de la démarche qui doit vous
permettre derrière de sortir de cette
emprise à caractère mental appelé à
l'instant si on a des doutes
effectivement sur un proche ou même sur
un parcours qu'on suit soi-même on peut
effectivement vous contacter vous disiez
que cette augmentation du spectre à la
fois des néoguroux et des victimes est
liées à ce moment d'angoisse que l'on
ressent tous collectivement d'une d'un
moment traversé par des crises pour
autant dans le dans l'histoire de nos
sociétés des crises il y en a eu des
moments d'angoisse aussi pourquoi à quoi
ça correspond d'un point de vue plus
large de la société de ce besoin de se
tourner vers voilà cette quête de sens
pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est plus prégnant
qu'il y a qu'il y a 20 ans qu'il y a 30
ans je crois pour affirmer que cette
quête de sens elle est intrinsèque à la
nature humaine et que ces interrogations
des ouvertures vers des traditions des
réflexions profondes à caractère
philosophique parfois ésotérique peuvent
se comprendre dans le quête dans la
quête de cette recherche de soi-même de
la compréhension d'une recherche d'une
forme de vérité et encore une fois c'est
votre droit absolu en France au nom du
respect de la liberté de conscience et
d'opinion
notre société est encore une fois en
plein bouleversement confronté à une
série de crises vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure en introduction crise
écologique la crise de la guerre en
Ukraine dernièrement la crise sanitaire
inédite qu'on n'aurait pas connu depuis
des décennies des décennies avec une
telle ampleur la question de la perte de
repère la question des différentes peurs
qui s'alimentent les unes avec les
autres et donc l'idée d'une forme
d'isolement parfois l'idée et le
sentiment de se retrouver seul confronté
à une perspective qu'on n'arrive pas à
dessiner
et c'est là où précisément les
prédateurs sectaires savent comment
exactement pouvoir ATI activer certaines
de leviers pour vous donner l'illusion
d'apparaître comme étant la plupart du
temps membre d'une forme d'élite capable
d'accéder à une forme de vérité et donc
on vous promet on parlait de la santé
des recettes miracles mais on vous
promet également une grille de lecture
vous permettant de vous rassurer et donc
de vous donner tout d'un coup une
direction possible à laquelle lorsque la
rhétorique est maîtrisée de la part des
des entrepreneurs sectaires concernés et
c'est la plupart du temps le cas lorsque
les méthodes utilisées permettent de
capter l'attention je parlais des
gourous 2.0 l'ensemble de ces
entrepreneurs sectaires maîtrisent
parfaitement les codes du web maîtrise
parfaitement tout ce qui relève du
marketing digital et savent également
comment faire en sorte en profitant des
possibilités offertes par le web de
établir un contact direct avec vous avec
des groupes et de d'essayer d'élaborer
au-delà de la doctrine qui est proposée
un lien de pouvoir établir un lien de
confiance soit disant avec vous en vous
promettant d'accéder à des théories à
des techniques à des vérités qui vont
vous permettre d'aller mieux de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans le monde
et de vous-même de vous inscrire dans
ces cas-là dans une perspective de
dépanouissement et de développement
personnel absolu et c'est là où ça peut
devenir dangereux lorsqu'il y a une
rupture
provoquée avec votre entourage avec
votre famille avec la société d'une
manière générale vous parliez de vérité
à pour l'instant de grille de lecture du
monde des notions qui ont été malmenées
on le sait depuis la crise sanitaire
est-ce que vous diriez qu'en ce sens que
le complotisme qu'on a vu prendre de
l'ampleur ces dernières années est une
forme de dérive secteur complotisme est
un phénomène social existant depuis des
siècles et des siècles la révolution
numérique a largement contribué à
réhabiliter d'une certaine manière à
certain nombre de ces théories et en
diffuser d'autres par la possibilité
offerte par la technologie et s'il y a
bien une distinction en fait entre ce
qui à faire entre ce qui relève du
complotisme et des dérives sectaires ce
que nous avons constaté aussi à
l'occasion du dernier rapport à travers
le travail effectué par l'ensemble des
collaborateurs et des équipes de la
mivilud c'est cette hybridation de plus
en plus forte entre ces théories à
caractère conspirationniste et les
dérives sectaires dans le sens où
beaucoup de d'acteurs de leaders de ces
phénomènes sectaires s'inspirent
dans des sillons tracés par ces terres
complotistes pour mieux contribuer à
couper les futurs victimes de leur
entourage allez couper la société et
c'est là où le processus d'enfermement
est encore plus marqué du fait de la
force de ces de ces théories là qui je
le rappelle sont également désormais
malheureusement un élément clé de la
culture du web aujourd'hui ces deux
questions très rapides d'abord première
question est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
impuissant face à ça sur les 4000
saisines que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure seul 20 ont donné lieu à des
signalements à la justice première
question et deuxième question est-ce que
ce phénomène mais je crois que ça donne
la réponse et franco-français
articles 40 activés c'est à dire qu'on
nous même à la mivilud des des
procureurs de la République
territorialement compétent
c'est tout à fait normal étant donné que
dans le cadre du droit français nous
avons besoin d'une multitude d'éléments
de preuves permettant d'engager une
démarche judiciaire mais au-delà des 20
dossiers concernés nous suivons avec les
différents services enquêteurs de la
gendarmerie de la police l'ensemble des
dossiers qui nous remontent et qui
remontent également directement ses
services au-delà de la mivilud vous
pouvez aller déposer plainte à votre
commissariat ou à la caserne aux
gendarmerie donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup plus de dossiers traités à
l'échelle nationale il pourrait répondre
à votre question il s'agit en aucun cas
d'un phénomène franco-français il s'agit
d'un phénomène à caractère mondial qui
malheureusement
s'adapte aussi aux spécificités
culturelles notamment de législatives
bien sûr des pays et sachez que beaucoup
de pays se sont tournés se tournent
encore vers nous en France étant donné
que nous sommes l'un des très rares pays
à pouvoir proposer à travers la misélude
une administration centrale qui soit à
la fois chargée de l'analyse de ces
phénomènes de la coordination de
l'action préventive et répressive avec
tous les services de l'État concerné et
qui se charge également du lien et de
l'accompagnement des victimes et c'est
un modèle qui visiblement intéresse
beaucoup de pays également concernés par
ce fléau début de l'année 2023 il y aura
les premières Assises des dérives
sectaires et du complotisme ici en
France merci beaucoup Christian Gravel
votre rapport le rapport de la misides à
trouver sur le site internet de cette
organisme public on le rappelle le
rapport qui fait 200 pages passionnants
merci encore merci on se retrouve juste
après la pause pour la suite de Paris
direct avec Damien coquet à tout de
suite
[Musique]